[Music]
okay everyone so this is my review
of the season four finale of the
handmaid's tale
the wilderness this is directed for the
first time
for the handmaid's tale for liz garbas
and it's written by show runner bruce
miller
okay so we open up with this voiceover
of june in her head from the past
in a moment where she was dancing with
fred in jezebel's
it shows her mindset again what it was
like in gilead where she had to pretend
like she loved fred and that that was
the way to survive
but she couldn't fight she couldn't bite
him as she says
and this sets up what june will do in
this episode of fred where
she again a little bit pretends in front
of fred and kind of
traps him into thinking there's some
love there but also
that it's setting up this theme for this
episode where
it's like this animalistic part that's
in all of us
will come out in june that she's
suppressing here in gilead
so in present day we see that tuello
has june now basically make her thoughts
on this possibility of fred going free
but they don't actually give her a judge
in person she says this
to a camera and he says oh they'll keep
it in the records here but
it's a total fu and it's really
something that's disheartening to june
but you see mark is informing june that
fred has been valuable but june's like
well you won't get him to shut up
weak men make the world go around and
she's talking about fred here but she's
also
giving a dig here to mark calling him
weak and it's important because what
really worked well in this episode was
how they dealt with mark as a character
and going back to
his kind of a weird obsession with
serena which we'll get more into as we
go on but this kind of plants the seed
to
june finally getting this man to come to
his senses and come
and turn now on the waterfords so after
june gives her statement what's
important here is when she goes outside
and looks up at the sky that's blue it's
cutting to her thinking about when she
was dramatically raped
by fred but that process of looking up
thinking of other things
looking at the blue that was happening
in gilead there and
what's happening here in present day is
it's showing you she's thinking about
that and she's not
healing right the way this is going down
with fred and him about to go free
this isn't good it's not making her feel
any better and
it's leading to her trauma really
kicking in and her thinking about
what happened with fred and informing
her decision what she's going to do here
because
this is a big episode for june because
she has to make a choice as we get into
as the episode goes on
june back at home here talking to
readers like rita i'm gonna need you to
stop serving me and stop cleaning and
read is like i'm working on that with my
therapist there's just a little humor
there that i really like
because it's just rita not being able to
shut off being a martha but moira comes
over now and says
that waterford's being sent to geneva
which is in switzerland
to have his immunity hearing and it's
just me or did it seem like samir wiley
just had her
like wisdom tooth pulled the way she was
talking it was very uh
strange i don't know if anyone else
caught that but what's interesting here
is moira telling
jun you know go testify in person you're
the most powerful person on our side to
really
have a chance to do anything here with
fred but june's right here where she's
like
it's pointless they've already made
their decision there's nothing else june
can do
through the court that would work she's
already done a testimony and that did
nothing but there's a great line here
where
she said that she made her points
already in testimony they all know what
he did
and that him giving them information is
more
valuable than what he took from me
so this is something that will speak to
a lot of people who've been through
similar situations like this
that you're trying to get justice the
right is supposed to win here
but they value the villain here and they
value his information more than actually
her own
worth and again like she says what was
taken from her so this really worked
well for me
and now when we go to fred we see a
little bit of him giving away
stuff about gilead but he's still you
know not giving the full thing here he's
still kind of lying
about his involvement in these
situations and he kind of rats out other
commanders here but what was more
important about this scene was actually
leading up to serena and she goes and
talks to toelo outside
now what's interesting is the first time
serena's really being the true serena we
know from earlier seasons when she's in
full life mode
too mark because she's spewing also
absolute nonsense
things like oh you know your woman in
there needs to be easy on fred and
she needs to start calling him a
commander then she wants faster internet
access
and then even says the ruling should be
expedited and she like scoffs like okay
great he gave june another little
chance for her to say something but
that's done now this is serena at her
worst
and this is mark seeing that and what's
really interesting about this and what
worked really well was
her showing her true colors to mark and
literally wearing her true colors while
they're showing this
in the blue when she's mentioning she
wants to go house hunting and mark has
this line you plan on living with the
commander as husband and wife and she's
like as a family of course
so he goes can you explain that to me
serena so this is like again
he's getting friend zoned right mark is
feels like he's been completely duped
and now it's coming true
what june had warned to him and said
that serena will
charm you she'll wrap you in and be nice
to you to get what she wants in the day
and she'll drop you and that's exactly
what's happening here with mark
and when i had interviewed the actor of
mark he had mentioned he believes the
character of mark has always kind of
had a love for serena so if there was
anything how messed up this man is mark
because
he was getting played by serena so well
that he chose
almost in a way making serena happy
maybe this idea that he'd eventually end
up with her
over june and over justifying june but
that is gonna flip here
because serena showed her cards here too
soon to mark i believe that if serena
didn't act this way in front of mark
right here
that mark wouldn't have eventually
flipped over to june's side in this
episode so now we get another very
important scene which is
june and emily on the stoop outside and
june mentions her mom saying that gilead
brought more old testament than the new
testament and emily quotes the old
testament
the righteous will rejoice in vengeance
and wash their feet in the blood of the
wicked
this is really telling you what's going
to happen by the end of this episode and
that's going to be june now
literally with her feet in the blood of
fred and getting
her vengeance and it's literally poetic
justice because it's now something
gilead would use against people being
used against one of their own but what's
so important character wise for june
here is her saying emily i really want
to let go of him
i want to focus on my family i want to
focus on hannah and my nicole and luke a
good mother would be able to let go
so this is a tricky decision our main
character jun has to make this episode
because
killing fred is justice right i think
she believes that it's what's going to
give her the most relief
in her trauma of thinking what happened
to fred but it
risks her relationship with her family
and what's going to happen for her
future
and you may be saying you know why
didn't she just let go
that maybe this is selfish because she
knows at the end of the day this is
gonna be it for her being around nicole
around luke and she's gonna be on the
run again but
if you take yourself out of the story
for a second and realize as a viewer
of tv this is still a tv drama that's
gonna go on and on right they've already
approved a season five so
this is something if you had her just
let go
and say you know what i'm not gonna do
this to fred and i'm gonna let go of it
and
try to live a normal life with my
daughter and luke
then the show's gonna be really boring
right what are we gonna watch them just
be
you know hanging around just doing
dishes like come on that's not what
they're able to do because if the show's
gonna keep going on
they can't just have it that she lets go
right so they have to go the opposite
decision
now if this was a movie and this was the
end of the movie they could have done
that or if this was the final you know
episode of the show as a whole
that's why i'm constantly saying though
i feel like we're getting to the point
where you know i don't know i feel like
we're
running out of story here for the
handmaid's tale and that i'd be more
interested right now in doing again
maybe the new show the testaments and
having that time jump in a different
story now because i feel like jun's
story's kind of getting
a little played out that's just me
though maybe you don't agree with that
but
i do think it's the smart choice for
jun's story going forward that she
would choose the path of vengeance here
and what's interesting is the next scene
june's you know i believe still on the
fence about this choice
and what to do with fred when she's
going to see fred and it reflects
when june was like a handmade going to
visit his office but this is a different
case now where she's seeing fred in this
room and they're in canada
and this was like the final make or
break test for fred i believe
for june and there's some key lines here
because when she's in the office with
fred
he says out of respect i hold no ill
will even after those things you said in
court
so this is strike one for fred you can
literally see june's face
just appalled at him saying something
like this and then he says i do
understand you have to frame things in
front of the judge and your husband
strike two right there but as much as as
a monster fred is
they always show they did in gilead when
he was you know playing i think it was
scrabble with june there's like
little ounces of humanity in this awful
person and i think that was
genuinely him saying sincerely that he
was sorry for child being taken
now that he imagined losing his own
child and you might say well hasn't he
experienced that when she took nicole
but he didn't even really
see that as his real child he sees this
child in serena's stomach as
his true bloodline his child this is
what gets him to see you know
the pain june must have felt and that's
why i think june does cry here a little
bit because it's like
oh my god wow there is something of like
humanity in this man actually
acknowledging that but again it's not
enough and it's
just silly that he can't really
understand other people unless he's gone
through it himself
but this is where creepy fred comes in
that we always saw with june and he's
like i wouldn't call it love but it was
something very strong and this can kind
of allude to you know that stockholm
syndrome type relationship but we know
from june's narration here it's a
her from her days in gilead that she was
again playing the game she was making
him
think that she loved him and she's doing
it here she has to bring that strategy
out one last time for fred to kind of
rope him in and then pounce
and you know what is interesting and i
liked about the writing here was her
saying she misses alfred
just like creepy fred does and the way
he says it but she misses her strength
right and it's
her bringing that back out in herself
and this can allude to you know why
people ask why she's still wearing the
red ear tag it's definitely that
it's that she it's like a reminder of
what she's went through and you know a
reminder of offering it's a reminder of
stuff she's overcoming what she's
capable of
and where the sad tragic part of the
story comes because
there's two sides to this finale where
it's victory
it's a vengeance this is a fan pleasing
moment you know what's gonna happen to
fred but there's
tragedy to it right and that's the part
of like what june's gonna have to now
sacrifice for that with
losing her normal life with this family
that's just not gonna happen
and that happens here when she's in the
car with luke and he's mentioning
grabbing a beer
then maybe going to boston seeing a red
sox game like they used to
but june knows like that's not this
story for june it's just
it's like sounds happy and fun but it's
it would take her away from what she's
really on a mission to do
and that's why she says i'm gonna put
fred on the wall and you see luke says
line like they're gonna let him go so
you got to let it go
and this again we know that you know the
luke type the rita type you know the
moira type they're more about like the
moving on and having justice in a
different way but what they do really
well in this episode shows
emily and june are on the same
wavelength of like pure vengeance here
and that's the only way to
treat someone like fred and that's why
she even says back to luke when he says
that you know
put him on the effing wall okay so then
june now is stalking
tooelo at his place and she's like i
need fred to get what he deserves
and he's like i don't know what i can do
for you but she's like just listen give
me a ride
and just listen so she's like come on
just hear me out here
but she sees there's like a break in
mark here that there is something in
there she's pulling out of him
and again i don't think that would have
fully came out unless he didn't just see
that june was right about serena and how
serena was just treating him but this is
where i
started getting really mad because this
is going from my frustrations from
i've said it last episode i've said it
for a long time now
about the character of commander
lawrence and i told you that he's a
plotbot
and i'm gonna say it again and it shows
more than ever here because this is the
third season in a row we go to season
two
where he was the key to getting emily
and jun out season three
he's the key to getting the kids out
season four now
he's the exacting the plot needed he is
the plot bot
to make june get her vengeance and make
this all make sense and happen which
really frustrates me it's so beyond
annoying because
to me it then waters down june being the
one who really accomplishes with her
smarts it's like
well hold on we need lawrence to get us
out of this writing block he's literally
kept on this show
to make the things happen that need to
happen and i hate it
so when i saw him in the diner i i
literally my eyes rolled
so far back i was like i cannot believe
they're doing this again this is the
third time they've used this trick
in a finale and a beat that he was going
to be the one to be the reason things
are able to happen here
so getting that anger out about that
because i don't want to beat a dead
horse but june and lawrence
put on their show in front of tullo and
this is the 22 woman they're going to
make the deal for for fred
and remember mark thinks that they're
making this deal and that fred will get
his justice
through the gilead system like we'll see
luke and rita allude to
right but that's not really what's going
on here that's not the final plan of
june
and what also annoys me about lawrence
okay i am going to rant some more but
lawrence also delivers our theme for the
next season
thank you he says literally it won't be
enough whatever happens to him if we get
him
won't be enough for you so he's
basically setting up what the character
arc of june's going to be next season
with by her making this decision to kill
fred that it it's never going to you
know
be enough for her to move on and it
might not give her what she thinks and
satisfaction and
that's the theme we've seen a lot of
shows but again it's just annoying that
lawrence is here to deliver our theme
and i don't think we need to hear it
either by the way i think we're ready to
see that and we can kind of read that i
think i was a little too telly but
going back to this what i was talking
about with luke and rita and moira and
they're
talking about you know fred's gonna
hopefully get his justice through the
gilead system
and emily's on the wavelength with june
she's like but he's still alive
and it makes sense that emily's you know
this
voice for june because june was that
voice for emily a couple episodes ago
but also
emily it's so consistent with her
character you know she at the end of the
day from this story has always been
the most i don't know word to say here
but like i'll say badass like she
literally drove over a man she's the one
who hit aunt lydia in the back she is
fearless and she goes the length she's
full measure so
it makes sense that she would be the one
the end of the day at the end
with june that's in the wilderness when
they attack fred and you see emily says
that great line of june like what do
you want you know it's not about what
everyone else is saying around you or
what they think should happen for fred
it's what do you want june
and june wants the full monty here she
wants him to feel the fear she felt when
she got caught
that is her version of justice she wants
to put him through the simulation of
what she went through now what was
interesting was this was like this final
scene now we're ever going to see is
serena and fred together
and she says it really is a miracle you
have done fred and fred says guided by
his hand and my love for the two of you
so
serena thinks they got a huge win here
and she's just ready to now do
interviews
get back to living a normal life she got
what she needed a friend she almost
looks him as like a business partner
right now
and is thanking him that they're gonna
basically go free
and she's ready to write her book and
she's like we'll have to divide and
conquer for a while knowing fred's gonna
have to go away for a bit but
we know now that that's not gonna be the
case it's really gonna just be serena on
her own
and you see fred's like we can try to
zoom i'd like to see you i like that
zoom's getting their little uh time in
the show here i mean look zoom's a
normal thing now so it makes sense that
shows are starting to use that on the
plot i actually like it and she's like
sure fred we can zoom so fred's the one
who still like
wants to have a relationship with serena
but serena it's only for her needs
at this point all she really cares about
is that baby and her book and
it's going to see what goes on with her
and the future of what she's trying to
create here but you see
what was really good about the directing
here was he has his last look at serena
forever through that door before he's
gonna go to his death sentence
and why that works really well is that
when we see june leave her house
she's the same kind of moment where
she's looking through the window at
moira
and luke with nicole it's a goodbye to
that
life like she knows sadly like when she
comes back
that's not a thing anymore and for moira
and luke it looks like they're gonna be
full-time parents again
i don't think they'll be thrilled about
that so mark takes
fred into the truck again this is june's
full monty move here
and he's gonna go through what june went
through he's afraid he knows he's going
back to gilead so at this moment he's
like oh my god like i'm gonna get
basically
trial there and be screwed but he's
taken over the border and there's
lawrence my favorite character
just waiting just like he did literally
in the same position
and feel same hat he did it season two
when he was like saying nice life to
emily
and he's there because he's the only
commander feasibly that would give over
fred now to nick and not just take fred
back to
the gilead court okay so this is where
at the end of the day with my review i'm
praising on this episode but
i'm very jekyll and hyde about the whole
episode and where the hyde part of me
starts coming out
is is hyde the bad guy in jekyll and
hyde whatever the bad side is
maybe that's jekyll maybe the jekyll
okay we'll go with jekyll june comes out
in the woods right
this moment was awesome until one the
kiss was so
dumb to me she had with nick this felt
like it was taking away from was so
important in that moment
with her getting her justice on fred it
felt like they were throwing in this
little like twilighty thing
there's a couple twilighty things i
didn't like about this but that to me
was a little corny
so then you know she's like okay you can
choose the gun or the whistle and of
course he's like you don't have
you know the guts basically to shoot me
so she blows the whistle
then we see emily come out right but
then it's like we see all these
women but like who are these people you
know because i don't think it was the
ones that were just released we saw them
walking the other way and they were in
different outfits on the bridge so i'm
like you know who are these
people that are with emily and june now
that she can just trust that won't spill
the beans of what happened here like i
was just
confused about that like maybe i would
have liked i know they were trying to
save it for the shock of them coming out
of the woods in this big moment
but how how did this come about this was
a little weird to me
but then you know there's a point of
this where it felt like maybe even the
sequence with fred was too long from
when he got in the truck
to towards the end of this episode and
there was a vibe where i felt like it
was like watching the scooby-doo villain
get caught which is like i don't know
i thought it was a little silly with
them running them through the woods
again we don't know who half these
people are
in this moment so i thought maybe would
have hit more if it was just like an
emily in june
and i honestly wanted to see they set it
up with her mentioned line in june where
she wanted to hang him on the wall
i wanted to see that i know they show it
at the end of the episode that he's like
on the wall which was like amazing shot
and disturbing as hell but it was
awesome
but it was like you know why did we not
see that happen i thought i would have
felt that more than just like again
these strangers fighting in the woods
but you know then it gets more twilighty
when
the theme about her right at the
beginning episode talking about like you
know don't bite and then she bites him
here
again this is silly to me this is too
much out of tone for the show again
feeling like twilight how many times
he's gonna say twilight
but the thing is i don't even think it
was necessary to have this theme about
this animal side coming out in june i
don't think
having even the flashback with her and
fred i think even that's okay
but the part about the biting and then
you know
that animal coming out in her i don't
think it was necessary i don't think you
actually needed it i think it was
already
enough that we were seeing her get her
justice as someone who's hurt her so
much
that have to kind of you know imply that
like this is her
you know side coming out of her that's
like that animal part of our brain i
don't know i just think it was
a bit too much that you maybe you need
to pull back a bit here and i don't mean
that and how you deal with fred i want
them to put more into how they dealt
with friend actually wanted to be more
gruesome
and i think it would have been more
gruesome and justifiable again if it was
just the characters that had weight to
fred not these random people besides
emily
and then actually see him get hung on
the wall and actually the act of it not
just seeing the visual
and it also kind of felt just out of
nowhere with the finger
being sent to serena i would have
actually like to see serena see the
finger
how can you leave that over the next
season i think it would have been
awesome if she opened the envelope and
was just like
oh my god so i felt it was just a big
missed moment there for serena we could
have saw but it looks like they're
setting her up now
to be the main antagonist for next
season that could be interesting but i'm
gonna share my thoughts about next
season in a second but
june comes home you know this is the
tragic part of it where it's like
yes there's a win she gets her justice
on fred this is a crowd-pleasing moment
it's awesome but then you know there's
the consequences there's
okay how do we keep the show going
forward conflict for june so
you know this is the tragedy of it luke
caesar this is the woman he feared she's
become
she can't now be a mother to nicole
right now she's gonna have to go on the
run
and it's like you know luke was gonna
see how luke views this you know he
might see this as selfish
but maybe not you know and it's what
they have to do to kind of keep story
going but that's where you're gonna feel
we're at a season five
now so it's like you're gonna feel it
stretch now okay this
show really supposed to be one or two
seasons story wise but
you know again they're gonna have to
milk this thing so i like you know the
show the shot of fred but i would have
liked to see more in that area and him
get hung
and that's a nice touch i got this quote
here i'm not going to even try to say it
but it's there you can read it
and that's you know a huge callback to
what was in the waterford's house with
june but
i'm very worried about where we're going
with season five in the sense of like
now i'm feeling it now i'm i'm ready to
say like more than any season
like okay this show is starting to pass
this expiration date here but this is
gonna happen
what's frustrating is that somehow
hulu's been around this long and only
has
one mega hit and that's handmade still
so because of that it's going to keep
going and going and going
and then they're going to have
testaments be another show they'll
probably have a third show you just look
at the walking dead with amc this is
what they do when they only have like
their
couple hits and it's frustrating because
you can see someone at least like
netflix and even hbo
they get multiple hits you know where
hulu and amazon prime it's like the boys
for
prime hulu for handmaid's tale and those
two shows i promise you you'll see
seasons of those shows until you're
probably dead so it's like
it's it's never going to end now i'm
starting to feel like okay i'm not that
excited for season five
because i'm not crazy about canada still
we're just gonna see june on the run
again
and i think the most interesting stuff
is probably the leaning into serena
stuff but
i'm sure they're going to go with
something with mark 20 now going back
and forth with maybe
getting tempted by serena again or
helping june
and i feel like we run of course with
luke's story moira's story so
i think the really interesting stuff
left is lydia with
you know janine and esther that could be
really interesting but i feel like jun's
story is just running out here
and you know i can make a prediction
bowl predictor season five
you know finale lawrence is gonna come
in and save the day again
can't wait but i'm ready for the
testament show i'm ready for a time jump
you know so that's what i'm looking most
forward to
but i'm gonna give this finale an 8.2
where i actually like the first half way
better
i don't think the whole biting animal
theme was
even needed but so be it and i think
that you get this crowd-pleasing moment
but
why did it feel so silly i don't no i
can't put my thumb in it but i think
i've said
my piece and how i feel but again if i
look at the season as a whole
i'm gonna give the season you know i
gave it a 9.7 after seeing the first
four episodes but now
adding them all up the whole season you
know i'll probably give this
whole season about a nine a good night
right and for me if i'm looking at
season's ranked i'd still go season one
the best but season four i'm gonna give
it
you know second best uh season two the
third best and the
probably the worst with season three but
it's still good but the difference is
yeah you're like oh wow steve you're
giving season four second best season so
you really liked it i did but
compared to other seasons it leading to
a next season
has set up to me the like we're just
running out of story i'm not i'm not
that excited for season five so
that's the unfortunate thing about all
this but let me know guys what you
thought of this one i love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can
i love doing these reviews for you guys
i loved everyone who was commenting
and that we got to talk about all this
stuff please stay with me subscribe the
channel i'll be reviewing a bunch of
shows
uh movies i do celebrity interviews as
well
and if you really like what i do here
you can become a member and support me
there's a bunch of different perks for
different tiers i'd really appreciate
that
and you can follow me on twitter
instagram and tic tac all at steve
barley show
and those i have short reviews i do at
movies they're only a minute long so if
you're on the go
you're on your phone you can watch it
any support please just stay around with
me because sometimes families tell goes
and then people disappear
so i'd love you to be on the journey
with me and try to enjoy shows and
movies with me
it's really fun and i'm grateful for
every single one of you and
until next time praise be